so in light of
my brother and i's new graphic novel
god's dog which is crowdfunding right
now in indiegogo i want to look a little
bit at some of the symbolism of saint
christopher
especially the aspect of his later
legend which has him crossing
a river you know carrying the young
christ child but we'll see that this
pattern
of crossing rivers and the relationship
with monsters
and also even the notion of a trick
being played and let's say being both
playing tricks and being the subject of
tricks will be an interesting way to
understand what happens at the end of a
world what happens you know in a similar
way as when we talk about how the fool
turns things upside down and turns
things right side up that mitzier has
hinted at in his book we're going to
look at
how that relates to saint christopher
the dog
the dog-faced giant monster that carries
christ across the river
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
now the relationship between monsters
and crossing rivers is one which might
not appear super obvious to everybody
right at the outset but it's because we
have to see it first of all in the right
categories we have to understand the
monster as representing the edge but
that edge has many forms it can be
straightforwardly a monster but it could
just be the idea of animality itself
i've often talked about these garments
of skin which are given to adam and eve
as this cover which covers their outside
this periphery on their edges well we
have to understand that on the edge of
our humanity is animality we have
something in common with animals which
is our body and so as we explore the
body and as we look at the
the aspect of us which dies then we will
encounter animality things in common
with them in terms of our desires in
terms of our fleshiness there are many
things which are related to animality
so once you understand that there's a
relationship between animality and
monstrosity monstrosity being something
like the ultimate version of that or you
know the ultimate version of this of
showing that in a human having a hybrid
human or something like that or some
human that's too big or that has that
has also has some kind of excess in one
aspect of themselves or another you'll
understand uh way more you'll be able to
understand so many more stories in
scripture as well so the first story we
need to look at in order to be able to
perceive that is of course the story of
the flood and so we often
understand the story of the flood as
this pure thing right noah is fleeing a
world of giants so he's fleeing a world
of monsters and to flee the world of
monsters he makes a boat and he crosses
over in that boat but the boat
is also full of animals and this is
a very important part of the symbolism
so what you want to do now is you want
to keep those images in your mind and
not necessarily right away look at what
side those images fall on that is
a river crossing or a water crossing
then the notion of animality then also
the notion of giants or monsters
different types of them so in this
version you'll see that and also the
notion of the strange like i've really
i've tried to explain to you how there's
a relationship between monsters uh
animality and the strange and the
stranger like and and the stranger not
in a specific way that is that every
identity has a stranger it's not about
specific groups or specific nations or
specific races it is in that case now
it's mostly about the idea that all
identities have on their edges something
which they see as strange and this is
relative to the identities but it's
objective in the sense of the pattern
that is that every single nation every
identity every family anything you can
identify will have something on their
edge which is a stranger and which which
can be recognized as such
and so in the story of the ark you have
the this stranger as the
the the
the strange spirits that come and mix
with the daughters of cain and so you
can see it one way or the other you can
see it as the angels you know
having relationships with something
which is strange to them which is the
daughters of cain but you can also see
it from the side of the humans having
encounters with these strange and kind
of wild spirits fallen spirits that are
creating these hybrid giants and now
these giants are there become
this phenomena at the end of the world
they create hybrids they create
technology they create all these things
and in order to escape that noah has to
flee in a boat which is full of animals
and so you can already see that he's
using something of death in order to of
course cross over the waters you see
that of course in the boat itself which
is a technology so the technology which
came from kane is now used in order to
cross over now this is made clear
in several legends that you can find um
you there are some led crazy legends for
example some traditions which say that
noah's wife is named nama and she would
also be a descendant of cain and so
noah's wife would be something of that
fallen world that is uh related that is
related to this flip or this trick or
taking something and turning it against
itself um there are also weird jewish
religio traditions about you know the
giant og uh you know
pulling the ark through the flood that's
how he got to the other side and so
there are plenty of ways of trying to uh
to kind of understand this but usually
to just see the elements and how they're
related to each other now
once you see that you'll notice that now
this pattern will repeat itself all over
the place in scripture but also even in
other traditions and so when the when
the israelites for example leave egypt
and so they're they're prisoners in a
land of strangers
they're slaves in the land of strangers
and now in order to flee
then what they'll do is they'll also
gather a bunch of strangers with them
a bunch of mixed multitudes now it's not
even it's not even just the um
not just the the egyptian but a mixed
multitude of different groups and
different identities think of it a
little bit in the way that uh for
example richard rowland in our
discussion has talked about the nest the
thing that protects you as a gathering
of random twigs which potentiality which
is brought together to create this ark
this boat this protection around you and
so that's what happens when the
israelites flee egypt and then they
cross the waters just like
in the in in the flood now in the flood
the the giants get lost in the flood in
now the crossing of the red sea the
egyptians with their chariots that's
important the technology
as it was there in the uh
before the flood now the egyptians are
described as having these war chariots
and so all of that is lost in the flood
the the red the crossing of the red sea
and on the other side now you have the
israelites with this mixed multitude
which have to now find a way to recohere
and to
come together under one common identity
this will of course happen when moses
receives the law and and has to prune
some elements of the tribe but
ultimately brings them together in order
to create israel but if you want to see
a version of this which is even crazier
it is that
when the israelites reach the promised
land because of a lot of because of
their doubts because of their own uh
refusal to accept that this was the plan
for them
when they reached the promised land
there are only two adults left of the
original group that left egypt
and those two
those two people are joshua and caleb
now joshua and caleb they were the
in tradition they were the the spies
that went into uh into jericho and had
this relationship with the prostitute or
that was in jericho there's a
relationship with that as well this
kind of relationship with those that are
on the edge of the other world as well
so you can imagine a world with water in
between
and
on the edge of this world like where we
are there are spies
giants
uh monsters guards all of these types of
things which exist on the edge and then
on the other edge there are those those
aspects of the society which are on the
edge of that one as well and so the poor
the the the prostitutes those that
aren't don't have a stake let's say as
much in the city but are on the edge of
that and there can be a relationship
between the two you can use this aspect
of this society
as a potential to create your
transformation right so you can
seduce the disaffected in order to bring
about change because the disaffected is
like a potential that is not that
doesn't have a stake in the current
system okay so this is what's happening
in this in the story of of joshua of the
two spies which go to jericho but now
when we come to the the actual
transition later when they they finally
do cross over the the river
the only two from the original group
that are left are joshua and jericho now
it's super interesting is to realize
that
joshua means jesus it's basically the
same name
and
caleb there is one reading of the name
caleb which is that it means dog
and
not only that but there's one of the
descriptions of caleb which is that he
is a stranger he's a kennezite and he's
told that he receives the edge of the
camp
so his people his group he he he
receives the edge of the the land which
they take in israel now it's very
fascinating because
modern scholars will hate this but there
is definitely
you think of this the sound of the
relationship between
kane and kennezite
there is definitely something going on
in that relationship not necessarily a
historical connection but people in the
ancient world would have seen this
connection in terms of sonority so you
have caleb the dog who is a kennezite
and who lives on the edge of the of the
camp now think about it you basically in
now the
in the old testament right in the book
of exodus you find the very image of
saint christopher which will appear
in the european middle ages of christ of
jesus
you riding in crossing the waters with a
dog
in order to reach
a new world in order to reach the other
world and that dog is uh an image of the
edge an image of the of the descendants
of cain as well and uh for example saint
christopher is said to be a canaanite
and a a canaanite in the sense of a
son of of canaan and now we have the
kennezites and we have the descendants
of cain all these sounds i know people
will think that this is arbitrary but
even though there there might not be
actual linguistic connection between the
two this for ancient people would not
have been arbitrary would have been a
way to put these things together in the
text in order to help you see the
connection that is being made to help
you intuit that there's a relationship
between these different things
so this is of course one example but
there are many other examples of this in
scripture as well and so for example
once again when elijah crosses the river
what does he use in order to cross the
river he uses his garments of skin
and so he actually uses the animal part
of him he uses this garment this outer
garment that he has which in scripture
has said that was a woolly garment so he
has this animal skin around him think of
these images we have a prophet you know
of saint john the baptist who wears this
animal skin and so now with this animal
skin he is able to cross the jordan
river and go to the other side
and in that story interestingly enough
there is a uh an ascension and so
this is something you'll see in a lot of
the stories which is that in the
crossing of the river there's something
which happens which is that the higher
principle
ascends up into heaven and leaves the
body down at the bottom in order to kind
of continue in this new world we see
this of course in the in the crossing of
the river into the promised land where
before
joshua and caleb cross over moses goes
up the mountain and
disappears and dies but it says in later
traditions that his body was taken up by
saint michael into heaven
and there was even a competition you
know between the devil and saint michael
for his body but this is to show this
kind of ascent before the transition of
into the next world
you see that of course now again after
elijah crosses the jordan river he comes
to the other side with his garments of
skin and then he ascends up into heaven
and he leaves behind
the body he leave behind this garment of
skin which has his power in it
and now you now it goes on into the next
world with his disciple elijah um so you
can really kind of understand this at
the manner in which you change worlds
because this is actually how you change
worlds you have to the them
the spirit of the first world has to go
up
has to kind of disappear and then
leave behind a new potential for the
spirit to come back down or a different
spirit to come back down in order to
bring about
the the next world um and so you see
that of course in the story like i said
of elijah and elisha
but there again are many others and you
know you will find
different versions of this in different
moments and they have different shapes
and i'm going to give you a few more but
there's plenty more if you want to look
for them so there is a story for example
of samuel the prophet samuel who is
brought put down into a cistern now
there are several versions of this story
where someone is put down into a cistern
and then is brought back out of the
cistern through a stranger now in the
story of samuel it's the most explicit
because samuel goes down into the
cistern and then an ethiopian man comes
and remember what ethiopians mean for
the ancient world it really is people on
the edge of the world people that are in
the extremes
and there is a relationship between the
ethiopians for for the the greeks for
the people of the mediterranean between
the ethiopians and these monstrous races
which are kind of exceptional which are
strange uh which are on the edges of the
world so this ethiopian comes
and he pulls samuel out and it's pretty
it's so funny because it's so explicit
in the story he pulls samuel out with a
rotten garment so now it's not a garment
of skin per se a garment of animal skins
but it's a garment of death in another
way so it's a rotten garment and he
pulls samuel out of the cistern using
this rotten garment
there are little hints of that in other
stories for example if you think of
the story of joseph who is also put in a
cistern and then is taken out in order
to be sold to the stranger to go into
egypt it's not exactly the same but you
can see those elements
come together and he's sold into slavery
to a eunuch
and you'll see that image of the eunuch
come back later so joseph is taken out
of this cistern to go into the strange
land uh and he is becomes a slave to
eunuch now
so that you'll see it later when we talk
about ethiopian eunuch you'll see that
there's a relationship between all these
things so fast forward now exactly let's
fast forward directly to the story of
the ethiopian eunuch now in the story of
the ethiopian eunuch in the book of acts
you have a lot of these elements now
coming together once again
and so the ethiopian eunuch is there you
know on the side of the road and he's
puzzled he doesn't understand the
scripture you know and the idea that the
stranger presents itself as a puzzle to
be solved um is something that we've
talked about many times we talked about
this in terms of the queen of sheba who
comes to solomon to present her puzzle
we've talked about it in many different
ways that the the sphinx this monstrous
creature which comes and poses its
riddles uh and this puzzle is like
it is it acts like a guardian right it
acts like something which prevents you
from entering into a world is like a
buffer of question or chaos between two
different realities um of course the
cherub on the
on the uh the veil of the altar that or
the the cherub which prevents you from
entering
into paradise as well so that the cherub
acts as a guardian to paradise in its
strange
kind of mixed uh
form remember that one as well because
we'll see it a little bit later too
um and so the the the ethiopian eunuch
is both ethiopian that is he comes from
the edge of the world and a eunuch just
like the eunuch in the story of joseph
that's a representation
of
for us let's say for for an identity of
the sterility of the strange to us that
is the strange doesn't
give us doesn't perpetuate our identity
and so it has an image of sterility to
it
and this is of course an extreme image
of sterility now what's interesting is
of course how christianity is going to
transform that is going to let's say
just like christ heals
the the the sick and also just like
christ when you hear the story of the
canaanite woman
who christ says christ actually refers
to as a dog
that she receives the crumbs from the
edge of the table that is she that she
asks for the crumbs from the edge of the
table and christ says you know that that
she has faith and so she will receive
even if she's very far away from christ
as this jewish messiah she will
nonetheless receive those crumbs which
will reach all the way to her now think
of that as a version of pentecost and
now in the story of the ethiopian eunuch
we have a great version of that which is
the ethiopian is represented in a
certain manner in this story as
something of a monster something of a
sterile
uh character um but who also is a
guardian of riches you know he's the
guardian of the the the treasure of the
queen of ethiopia just like the sphinx
and all these creatures are also kind of
guardians of treasures because their
potentiality and if you can if you can
if you can encounter it properly then it
yields all this potentiality and this is
what we see in this story again so now
philip the apostle philip comes to the
ethiopian eunuch and explains to him the
scripture
and then ultimately he baptizes the
eunuch now this baptism
is related to elijah crossing the waters
with the garments of skin that is
philip goes into the water with this
this man who represents the sterile the
strange the
the edge all of these things goes into
the water because in also you have to
remember that in uh
israelite culture in the
in the old testament someone who is
castrated someone who is a eunuch could
not enter into the temple he was
considered impure and so could not enter
into the sacred space
but now what philip is doing is really
transforming this so he brings the
ethiopian eunuch into the waters
baptizes him and then philip
vanishes goes up into heaven
and you think why is that necessary like
why does this have to happen well it's
referring again to the story of elijah
and elisha even the words that are used
it says and philip was seen no more
something like that
is a direct quotation of the greek
version of the story of elijah and
elijah when elijah goes up into heaven
it says that elijah was was seen no more
and so philip goes up and leaves behind
now this transformed this new world this
new possibility for christianity and
christianity
will constantly be this image of the
capacity for
the divine logos for meaning for
encounter to reach further and further
out into the land of what before was
considered the
let's say um infertile strange
and you can see this in many many
aspects of christianity which doesn't
just does it isn't just like a giving in
to the strange but always tries to find
a balance between its kind of inner
relationship of love and then its
encounter with the strange this is of
course the two uh pillars of the church
saint peter as the pillar of the
circumcised church that is the pillar of
the church of those that have removed
the garments of skin around their around
their member and then saint paul as the
apostle to the pagans the apostle to the
gentiles the apostle to
the ethiopians and all the the the
peoples that are further and further out
from them on the edge of the world so
it's there in so much of christian
tradition
one of the traditions in christianity
for example is that you are not allowed
to marry within your family and there
are some some of those are really wild
like there are some traditions which
bring it to the seventh degree that is
you're not allowed to marry
seven degrees of family that is the
cousin of your cousin of your cousin
obviously these were always
they i don't think they were really able
to follow this properly but the
principle is there which is that you
need to marry out
and you need to marry out so that the
kingdom of god increases and kind of
becomes bigger and bigger as the as the
kingdom progresses even in terms of of
marriage and in terms of relationships
now
now of course this whole story this
movement this this idea of the
transformation of that which is on the
edge the transformation of that which is
which is uh monstrous or the the healing
of that which is sterile all of this is
of course
summed up not so much in the story of
the ethiopian unit but summed up in the
story of christ himself
all the things that he does all the
movements that he does towards the
margins but then ultimately in the story
of the death and resurrection of christ
especially as it takes its fuller image
in in the different legend the different
representations where christ goes down
into death and you know gathers all of
death together to bring it up with him
the idea of using death against death
this whole notion of the trick which is
also played on death is super important
this whole imagery we see in the gospel
of nicodemus of christ going down into
hades and death
and hades and the devil kind of you know
talking about how they've won they've
done this you know they killed the son
of god and so now they're they they
basically won the battle but then being
surprised by christ coming in as a
conqueror and basically taking on death
and so there's a trick which is
happening on death where
death thought that it was winning and
ultimately it's the light which won it's
the resurrection which took over
and so this of course now brings us to
the story of saint christopher himself
and so
in the legend of saint christopher the
one that is the most known about him
which is probably a later tradition
according at least to the scholars who
we don't we don't trust them that much
but you know whatever that doesn't
bother me to think that this is a later
tradition now this is the story of the
the the legend of saint christopher this
this part of it which is that saint
christopher is a monstrous giant
sometimes dog-faced canaanite
and so he's a canaanite in many ways
he's a descendant of canaan
that is the giants that were there in
the old testament in the land of canaan
but ultimately he's also something like
a
a descendant of cain in a in a in a more
metaphorical way that is through the
sonority of the relationship between
cain
and canite and canine you know all of
these things come together so much that
the scholars will tell us
that it's just all errors of
transcriptions where they made a mistake
between
uh cain in terms of the the son of adam
and eve then canine in terms of dog and
canaan in terms of the land where the
israelites came into but as we know
the manner which symbolism happens
doesn't necessarily have to account for
mechanical causation by through
attention that is that the fact that
people were able to be able even in
terms of trans transcription the fact
that they would be able to confuse those
that those
errors in transcriptions would uh make
sense to those that read them later
means that the connection is there
and can help us understand what it is
that's going on
so the story has him as this dog-faced
warrior in the land of kanan and
what he has is he has this insight he
wants
to serve the strongest king the
strongest man in the world the strongest
being and so he kind of leaves his
edge of the world this land of this
strange land of dog face monsters giants
and he
encounters a king a great king
now
he goes to the king and sees in him like
wow this king is super powerful i want
to serve this king so he enters into the
service of the great king and of course
is very appreciated by the king because
he's a very fierce and powerful warrior
but one day
saint christopher at this moment he's
called a reprobus actually he's not
called saint christopher repuribus is a
good name for a monster isn't it and so
rep rebus is uh sees that this canaan
this canaanite uh king this this
powerful king is afraid of the devil
uh you know he avoids saying the word
the devil or different ways of showing
that he's actually afraid of the devil
and so you know reprobus is curious and
asks
the uh
the king he says like who is this so
who's this devil figure
now the king doesn't want to tell him
and he says well look if i tell you who
the devil is
then you'll leave me
and you'll go serve the devil right
and this is where now saint christopher
appears as a trickster reprobus is a
trickster because he tells the king
if you don't tell me who the devil is
then i will leave you
and of course the king is forced to tell
reprobates who the devil is and no
surprise here
reprobabilist represents the king to
find the devil and so the king has been
tricked
he finally comes to serve the actual
devil
and enters into the army of the devil
now think about this like he becomes a
saint later so he serves the devil and
uh you know he's the devil's super
powerful obviously most powerful being
there is
um and he realizes that the devil is
afraid of the cross
and so he's like okay well what is this
thing like if the devil is afraid of it
it's got to be very powerful so he asked
the devil what's this whole thing about
the cross like you know what is this
about and the devil says well i'm not
going to tell you who this christ figure
is
if i tell you then you'll leave me right
same thing as in the first story
and
repromus plays the same trick he says if
you don't tell me then i will leave you
the devil is forced to tell reprebus and
of course repermis leaves and so now the
devil has been tricked
so riberbus goes out
and he wants to find
this christ he's like i want to find the
most powerful being in the world i want
to find this christ
and he doesn't find christ right away
but he encounters monks and he's asking
about he's like i need i'm looking for
christ you know i'm looking for christ
and the monk says well you know i can
show you how to find christ if you want
and reverse is like all right you know
this he's the most powerful being so so
uh so i need to uh so tell me how to
find christ um and so the monk says all
right so if you want to find christ if
you want to serve christ then you have
to pray
and so forever this is like okay he's a
monster he's a giant dog-faced you know
you know maybe possibly used to be a
cannibal monster and he says he's like
no i can't i can't i can't do that i
can't uh
i can't pray so all right the monk says
okay so if you if you can't uh pray
then maybe you should fast
and again repurposes like fasting no
it's not gonna happen you know he is a
monster
after all
uh and so the monk says you know what
you could stand next to the river
right and
when people come to you
you can cross them over the river
because there's no bridge and it's
dangerous
and so repurposed is like you know what
i can do that i can do that so he goes
next to the river
so think about now what's happened and
so
the the the monk has asked christopher
to
do two things he's asked him to
pay attention
and pray
and he's asked him to
remove these garments of skin fast so
cut off the excess
and focus on the highest thing
those are the two aspects right of how
we cohere we have to remove and and we
have to eliminate the the the periphery
and the things that aren't part of the
identity and then we have to cohere
towards
towards to the single identity that
constitutes things and uh
he couldn't do either right because he's
a monster that's what he is he's an
idiosyncrasy he's he's he's all those
things on the edge um
but
this is where we see the mystery of what
can happen and so he is potential
and so as potential as a body
right he is the one who can cross over
the river he's the one who can bring you
across like a boat like uh
like uh you know like the garments of
skin
and so he's crossing people over the
river and then one day
a young child baby you know very small
child comes to him and asks
reprobus to cross him over the river so
rephrabis you know takes the child puts
him on his shoulder starts to cross the
river and so as he's crossing
he becomes heavier and heavier and
heavier
to a point where
biss feels like he's going to go under
like rubber would feel like he's going
to die he's going to he's not going to
be able to make it across the river
and so there are different virgins
sometimes he asks them in the middle of
the river sometimes he asks him when he
finally was able to cross over uh none
it doesn't matter which one and so let's
say he crosses over puts the child down
and then asks the child like why
were you so heavy
and the child answers because i was
carrying
the
sins of the world
and then
you know what happens right i've already
told you what happens
then christ
vanishes
goes up into heaven you know because
that's how it works like that's how this
crossing pattern works
and saint christopher is has crossed the
river now there are different versions
of what happens after he's crossed the
river in some versions he realizes now
he's transformed back into a human
person in other versions of the story he
he has a a staff that has that virgins
he has a
dead piece of wood that now starts to
grow leaves and branches okay so you can
understand what it is it is this new
world he has moved across the waters and
he is
the one who will act as the potential
and the
the capacity for the world to start
again um and so but the most interesting
thing the most interesting thing in this
story is that
all this time
reprobus and of course he's renamed
christopher right after he crosses the
river that's where he's renamed christ
carrier but all this time reprobus
tricked the king of canaan tricked the
devil
but now
he's been tricked
he's been tricked to his salvation
that is he wanted to serve the strongest
man in the world
and what he ends up doing is serving the
weakest possible thing a baby
and so he actually thinks
he how can i say this he thinks that
he's serving the weakest thing
and is being tricked into
actually serving
the strongest
and he would not have even been capable
of seeing that that's also the that's
also let's say the
the insight you need to to get here he
would not be able to see the strongest
thing or the highest thing because the
highest thing is often hidden is often
hidden like a seed
it's actually not that visible it's
actually not the thing that is the
shining thing in armor the highest thing
is the hidden spiritual transformation
which occurs inside inside people the
highest thing is the monk hidden in the
cave somewhere in a mountain
who prays all day and all night and you
don't see and you don't hear about but
who is actually holding the world
together and so here we can see this
double trick this double inversion that
metzier and i talk about you know of how
death is used uh to transform to there's
a trick played on death and the trick
that christ played on death when he went
down into hades and surprised hades by
taking it over
is similar to the trick that that christ
is playing on repurbus as he crosses the
water coming to the other side and
finding that he has now been saved and
that he is now in participating in
furthering the kingdom of god uh out
into
the the out into further out into the
world and so these are the things you
need to meditate on if you want to
understand what is possible at the edge
and if you are interested in the the
the graphic novels that my brother and i
are starting this is the what we're
going to be exploring not just in the
story of the graphic novels but in the
very existence of them that is as the
comic books as being one of the lowest
uh forms of art in the 20th century
recognized as one of the lowest forms of
art or the most popular the most trashy
all of this
also because we play in this ambiguous
sphere of fiction and storytelling we
create anachronisms in the story we do
all these things which actually for some
people will seem suspicious at the
outset um but knowing uh and especially
for people who will have the insight
knowing and perceiving that there is
actually a trick being played a trick
hopefully to towards in the direction of
salvation and so i hope you found this
interesting as you've probably seen i
love saint christopher i love the story
of saint christopher and we'll probably
do another video which going to talk
more about dog-headed men in general and
possibly of course talk about giants and
so thank you for your attention
everybody and i will talk to you very
soon
i want to present you a new series of
graphic novels called god's dog
god's dog is a very loose and epic
exploration of the legend of the
dog-headed warrior saint christopher one
of the most surprising and peculiar
traditions of the ancient medieval world
it was written as a screenplay by myself
and my brother mature over 10 years ago
and the story was taken up and even
recommended by script scouting agency it
was requested by several hollywood
studios
but this story was of course too big too
strange too surprising for hollywood
and so now
with all the control of its potential we
bring you this groundbreaking story the
full color is a series of graphic novels
the story is set in a token-style
mythical version of the biblical world
filled with hidden codes ancient relics
angels giants dragons and populated with
fictional virgins
of mysterious monks warrior saints
and more symbolism than you can imagine
god's dog contains all the intensity and
subtlety of our symbolic thinking the
world class layouts and artwork of
cornilson all of this bound in a
mysterious and powerful story arc which
is available to all
from wide-eyed ten-year-olds to the most
seasoned of readers
the entire story with all its action and
complexity is already completely worked
out and the first book
is near completion
now all we need to do is deliver it to
you
we're crowdfunding this because
it is only the first step
we've already been contacted by even
international publishers for this
but we want to knock this out of the
park so that our artists can do this
full time and deliver the oncoming books
at a regular and steady pace
under our control
i myself will personally not be taking
any profit from this first book but
rather i want to use this to build what
we need to tell this full epic with all
its cosmic proportions
so along with the graphic novel we are
also producing a crowdfunding only
add-on the secrets of god's dog source
book a beautiful volume in which you
will find my original drawings for more
than 10 years ago an exploration of the
symbolism of saint christopher and an
exclusive text by matsuya pejo on the
symbolism of the biblical samson
this is the first thing that matthew has
published since his groundbreaking book
the language of creation
so jump into the margins with us be part
of this shift in storytelling where the
end becomes the beginning and where the
monster carries the king
into a new world
you